et en Ukraine où la guerre va rentrer le
mois prochain dans sa 3e année après le
bombardement sans précédent qui a fait
25 morts samedi à Belgorod en Russie les
alertes sont incessantes côté ukrainien
bonjour Emmanuel Chaz vous êtes à keV
notre correspondante en Ukraine une
capitale visée depuis quelques heures
par une pluie de missile c'est
ça oui tout à fait on a été réveillé il
y a quelques heures par de très fortes
explosions ici en centreville et lorsque
ça arrive et bien par exemple comme
c'est mon cas on n pas le temps d'aller
en en sous-sol d'aller s'abriter dans
une station de métro la plus proche pour
moi il faudrait que je marche plusieurs
minutes donc en pleine rue au moment des
explosions ce qui n'est évidemment pas
envisageable donc pour toutes les
personnes dans cette situation on se met
au milieu de son appartement à l'abri
avec plusieurs murs entre soi et les
fenêtres ça peut paraître dérisoire
quand on sait ce qui est envoyé sur la
tête des Ukrainiens on parle de plus
d'une dizaine di de missiles hypersonic
kinjal qui ont été exclusivement dirigés
contre des infrastructures civiles des
infrastructures énergétiques donc pas de
cible militaire il y a beaucoup de
dégâts dans plusieurs quartiers de la
capitale les services de secours sont
déjà sur place souvent pour éteindre des
incendies qui sont provoqués par la
chute de débris il y a pas forcément de
missile qui atteint sa cible et qui
explose sur sa cible en revanche ils
sont abattus interceptés par la défense
anti-aérienne ukrainienne au-dessus ou
pas loin de ces cibles évidemment en
tombant les les débris créent des
incendies blessent également des gens
pour l'instant on n pas encore un bilan
humain mais on sait que plusieurs
bâtiments de la capitale sont privés
d'eau d'électricité suite à ces frappes
et ces frappes polline et bien continue
nous sommes encore à l'abri car nous
attendons nous attendons nous nous
attendons à de nouvelles vagues de
missile lancé sur la capitale
ukrainienne Emmanuel ça fait presque 2
ans maintenant que les Ukrainiens
connaissent des scène comme celle que
vous venez de décrire à Kiev mais dans
le le reste du pays et en particulier à
l'est de l'Ukraine dans quel état
d'esprit sont-ils ces Ukrainiens en ce
début de nouvelle
année et bien écoutez c'est vrai que les
frappes se sont intensifié depuis
quelques jours en revanche de telles
attaques elles se préparent sur des
semaines des mois elles ont un coût
énorme pour le gouvernement russe ce ne
sont pas des attaques qui interviennent
du jour au lendemain ce qui met aussi en
question le narratif la narration russe
que c'est frappes interviendrai comme
punition je mets ça entre guillemets
après les supposées attaques
ukrainiennes contre Belgorod lancer des
missiles hypersonique contre un pays en
vague successive et bien ça se prépare
bien en amont alors les Ukrainiens ils
ont conscience de ça ils sont je dois
vous dire ils sont furieux de voir que
ces ceses ces attaques incessantes et
bien se multiplient que leur pays est
détruit ils en appellent à l'aide
internationale ils sont inquiets aussi
car ils voient que cette aide et bien
elle est un peu elle est un peu en
suspens on ne sait pas trop ce qui va se
passer pour cette année alors que les
bombardements il continue tous les jours
je vous parle depuis qui je vous décris
la situation dans la capitale mais une
attaque similaire est en train de se
dérouler à harkif également où il y a
déjà un mort il y a plusieurs blessés
plus d'une vingtaine dont un vieux
monsieur de 91 ans donc une fois encore
ça montre que les civils sont toujours
la première cible des Russes et payent
toujours le prix de ces attaques
aériennes qui je le rappelle se déroule
tous les jours sur le sol ukrainien
depuis presque 2 ans presque 3 ans
maintenant
Emmanuel chass depuis Kief